take a quadratic function and apply
gradient descent to find its minimum one
thing that you will notice immediately
is that it bounces around the main
reason gradient descends zigzags in this
fashion is because it's completely
amnesiac it keeps absolutely no memory
of the past if the negative gradient
points to the left it goes to the left
and if at the next iteration it points
to the right then it goes to the right
and this effect is even more pronounced
if the graph of the function is flat in
one direction and narrow on the other we
can actually make things more precise
the ratio between the length of the
longest and shortest principal axis of
this ellipse squared is called the
condition number and is traditionally
denoted by kappa the closest kappa is to
1 the nicer the function is and the
faster it is to get to the minimizer
this intuition can be formalized it can
be shown that in order to get to within
epsilon of the minimizer we need kappa
times log one over epsilon iterations
therefore a large condition number can
make gradient descent takes a large
number of iterations to convert and now
we get to momentum gradient descent this
is a very simple yet extremely powerful
idea to fight this problem and to
accelerate convergence of gradient
descent here is how it works
when you are at iteration k you compute
the gradient just as you would in
vanilla gradient descent
but now instead of just following this
gradient right away you first
extrapolate the previous direction a
little bit further and only then you
follow the negative gradient and you can
think of this extrapolation step as
momentum carrying from previous
iterations
and you can already see in this toy
example the benefit of this seemingly
small modification
formally we can show that with momentum
gradient descent we only need square
root kappa times log one over epsilon
iterations
so the time saving can be huge if kappa
is large
momentum gradient descent is actually
useful well beyond quadratic functions
for example nesterov looked at smooth
strongly convex functions and developed
a close variant of this method where
instead of taking the gradient of the
current iterate you first extrapolate
and compute the gradient at the
extrapolated point he showed that this
method that now takes his name is faster
than any other algorithm that relies
solely on computing the gradient of
course most functions that you want to
optimize in real life are not convex let
alone quadratic but even then
momentum gradient descent is still
widely used because it performs very
well in practice to understand just how
powerful this idea of momentum gradient
descent is
let us see not to one but two
interpretations of how it works
the first interpretation is quite simple
when you unpack this recursive formula
you realize that momentum gradient
descent keeps an exponential moving
average of past gradients
the second interpretation is even more
beautiful you can visualize the current
iterate as a particle swimming in a
potential field given by the function f
with friction
the force felt by the particle is the
negative gradient of this function
newton's law of motion force equal mass
times acceleration let us then link this
force to the acceleration of the
particle
integrating over a small unit of time
gives us the velocity of the particle to
which we add a friction term minus mu
times vt minus one integrating a second
time gives us the position of the
particle and after a trivial or
parametrization we recover momentum grid
and descent this was momentum gradient
descent in three minutes if you liked
the video
make sure to like and subscribe and see
you next time